Before we start, I'd to
say that I hope that everybody is well
and healthy
in their respective homes.
We are having a brief shutdown during
these few days here due to
some of the holidays that have
come about and
it's not really the holidays. It's not
that
most of the Muslims are
celebrating Thanksgiving per se,
but it is a time that is used for
visitation of family and friends
because most people have that time off.
So, because of this,
we had taken the decision to close the
masjid for a couple of weeks just
as a precautionary measure for all of
our patrons. So,
indeed, it seems we're almost a week
through and
about
nine more days left or so. Shall Allah
and things will be back to normal.
Tonight in sha Allah to Allah in our
in our
journey through Zad al-Ma'ad fi hadyi
khayr al-ibad authored by
Shaykh al-Islam Shams al-Din ibn
Qayyim al-Jawziyyah rahimahullah
we are going to be discussing
the
issue of the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam and how he would pray at
night.
How he would pray at night.
This is different than the previous
chapter.
If you'll recall with me, the previous
chapter was regarding the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam and al-sunan
al-rawatibah.
The
sunan that are more
attached
to
the prayer
the five daily prayers than they are to
the time of day or night.
These are al-sunan al-mu'akkadah.
Al-rawatibah. These are the sunan in
which the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam would pray
all of the time. Sometimes he would
pray a little more. And in travel he
would pray less. However, we discussed
10 raka'at, 10 units of prayer.
And we also discussed the importance
of the two raka'at before Fajr and also
the one raka'at before after Isha,
which is al-witr, witr salah.
There are a couple of things that we
need to
finish up with regards to
that topic.
Number one,
with regards to witr salah.
Witr salah, which is essentially one
raka'.
When we talk about witr,
witr in the Arabic language articulates
al-fard.
It articulates
singularity.
Right?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uses al-witr
in the Arabic Quran.
In the Quran, excuse me, he uses it
as a kind of contrast or antonym to
even numbers, which are a shaf'a. So,
he says wa shaf'i wal watri.
Right?
So, what this means is, as the scholars
of tafsir, some of them have mentioned,
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala swears by
the even and odd.
Right? So, witr,
the odd number, right? Even numbers are
any number.
The odd number,
which often times we say even numbers
are divisible by two,
right?
Two equals
and odd numbers are singular.
The essence of what
the odd number is is one extra.
It is one. One rak'.
And this is why the correct opinion of
the scholars of Islam
mentions that the minimum for witr salah
is one rak'.
And this is why sometimes the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wa sallam would pray
that one rak' by itself, and sometimes
he would pray it
with
two others, making it three. And
sometimes five, and sometimes seven, and
sometimes nine. He had prayed it
[Arabic recitation]
together.
Right?
So,
this one rak',
we have evidence of it from the
companions
on them,
that in Sahih al-Bukhari,
in the book of Fada'il al-Sahabah,
the virtues of the companions,
amongst other places throughout Sahih
al-Bukhari,
Imam al-Bukhari mentions under the
heading Muawiyah on them,
and in this heading,
he mentions a narration in which
Muawiyah ibn Abi Sufyan on them,
prayed one rak' in the masjid after
salah.
He prayed Isha, which means he led
everybody in Isha,
and then he prayed one rak',
and then he left.
And one of the companions of Ibn Abbas,
one of his students, observed
Muawiyah doing this. And so he
mentioned this to Ibn Abbas, and he
said,
you know, Muawiyah prayed one rak' on
its own, alone.
And Ibn Abbas on them
said, "Dahu fa innahu faqih."
He said, "Leave him.
Don't speak ill of him. Don't speak as
if this is
something that is wrong, because indeed
Muawiyah is a jurist. He is a faqih. He
is very knowledgeable with regards to
the laws of Allah." And so,
taken from this and elsewhere, that
the witr salah is essentially one
rak'.
We have this also in a narration in a
sunan,
in which a man asked the Prophet
on him and them
about night prayer, meaning how to pray
night prayer. He said, "Salat al-layli
mathna mathna." He said, "Prayer at
night should be performed in units of
two."
He says, "Prayer at night should be
performed in units of
two."
He said,
"And if you fear that Fajr is going to
rise while you're still praying, meaning
if
just before Fajr comes in,
pray one rak', and that will make odd
all of the the number of prayer that you
had throughout that night."
And so, the scholars of Islam took from
this narration that
one rak' is sufficient as witr.
And there are different ways that that
would be prayed. So, sometimes the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam would
make one rak'.
Sometimes he would make three.
Now, when makes three rak' in witr,
he's going to do them all three with
only one tashahhud at the end.
Only one tashahhud at the end.
So, he is not to make witr Maghrib,
where you're going to pray two rak'
and then you're going to sit for
tashahhud and stand and make another la.
There is no first tashahhud in witr. If
a person makes three, he prays three
consecutively and makes tashahhud only
at the end.
Likewise, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam was narrated to have made five
altogether in the same way. Five rak'ahs
consecutively
and one tashahhud at the very end.
Also, Aisha narrates that he had made
seven.
And when a person makes seven or makes
nine rak'ahs, and I know this is kind of
kind of strange to some people because a
lot of people haven't heard of of these
things that I'm mentioning.
when he would make seven or nine
raka'at as is in a sunan,
he would pray
six and make tashahhud
after the sixth raka', then he would
stand up and make another and then make
a final tashahhud.
The same thing in nine. At eight, he
would sit, make tashahhud, stand up, and
then he would make tashahhud again in
the ninth.
This is how the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam performed witr salah.
But it's important for us to know that
the essence of witr salah is one
raka'.
And so, when we are speaking about witr,
we are speaking about one raka'.
And when we are speaking about sunnatul
fajr, we are speaking about two.
Right?
We are speaking about two.
Now,
how many can a person pray throughout
the night? They can pray as much as they
like.
However, they should make the finality
of their prayer one raka'
as the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam told the companion, "Salatul
layli mathna mathna."
The prayer at night should be two
and you performed in units of two and if
you
see that fajr is about to
come, the break of dawn is about to
come, then you should make one raka'
and it will make odd what is past.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
highly encouraged salatul witr.
He encouraged it with both his statement
and actions.
So, he encouraged it with his statement
by saying,
"Inna Allaha witrun yuhibbul witra."
[Arabic recitation]
So, he was narrated to have said, "Allah
is witr." Meaning, he is one, and he
loves that one raka'
at the end of prayer.
Likewise, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said in another narration, "Oh,
people of the Quran,
upon you is witr." Meaning, people of
the Quran, those who are praying at
night and reciting the words of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala contemplatively.
Another thing that we need to mention is
just because witr is encouraged to be
the last
prayer of the night,
doesn't mean that it is wrong to pray
after salatul witr.
Right? What I mean by this is, let's say
a person wishes to wake up after
sleeping some hours to pray at night.
And this person wishes to wake up after
However, they are afraid that they might
not wake up.
Okay?
So, they do want to pray witr, but they
also want to pray at night.
A person can pray witr and go to sleep.
And if he wakes up, he prays or she
prays again. Back to the narration we
just learned, salatul layli mathna
mathna.
Prayer is to be performed two raka' at
a time. Right?
However, the person does not
make witr again. If you've already made
witr, you're not going to make it again.
There is a narration that states,
[Arabic recitation]
fi laylah,
while the narration itself
is differed upon, the meaning is
correct, and that is that no witr should
be performed twice in one evening. No
witr should be performed twice in one
evening cuz that defeats the purpose of
witr. Now it becomes even, right? And so
that is with regards to witr salah. So
if a person were to pray witr and then
go to sleep and then wake up before fajr
and wish to pray again, that is fine.
That is fine, but they would not repeat
witr salah.
Another issue, which is the two rak'
of fajr.
When should a person pray the two rak'
of fajr? If they miss
the two rak' of fajr,
the answer is
it is permissible
to pray right after fajr,
and it is permissible to wait until the
sun rises to pray two rak'.
Right?
we have this in two narrations. In
one narration, the Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam saw a man, a companion,
praying after fajr.
And the asli is that a person does not
pray after fajr. After you have made
prayer, after you have made fajr salah,
you are to not pray until the sun has
risen
risen about about 15 minutes after sun
sunrise.
And so
he asked this companion what he was
praying, and he said, "I missed the two
rak' before fajr, so I'm praying them
now."
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
did not respond.
This is a type of sunnah, which is
classified by the scholars as sunnah
taqririyyah,
which means that the Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam affirmed
this action. He didn't say, "Don't do
this. If it was wrong, he would have
said to him do not do this.
But when he asked him and the man
answered and he said nothing and left
him be, this articulates that he
he
is doing something correct, right?
And so, it is permissible to do this or
that.
What is better? The scholars differ on
that. What is better is after the sun
has risen because
all of these scholars agree that that
time is is fine.
Likewise,
another issue is before Fajr.
When a person when the adhan for Fajr is
made,
the sunnah is that a person make two
rak'ahs for
sunnat al-Fajr and then make no more
salah. And we see this often. People
will come to the masjid
and when they come to the masjid,
they'll start making two rak'ahs, two
rak'ahs, two rak'ahs, two rak'ahs as if
it is
Jumu' or something until the Imam
prays. That may be
okay for any other prayer, but for Fajr,
always the legacy of the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wa sallam was that two
rak'ahs and then wait until Fajr.
Wait until the obligatory prayer.
Another issue that is very confused,
many people are very confused about,
is
the narration
There are a number of narrations about
this, but the gist of the collection of
meanings in these narrations
is that there are three main times when
a person is prohibited from praying.
Okay?
What are these times?
Number one,
after Fajr salah until the sun has
risen.
Number two,
just before
the sun reaches the zenith, the center,
exact center of the sky,
person is not to pray until it crosses
its zenith, right? Which is noon.
And the third time is after Asr until
the sun sets. These are the three times.
Okay?
So, if a person has made Salat al-Fajr,
they are not to pray
as the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam instructed,
until the sun rises
about a cubit above the horizon, which
again, this is a type of measurement
that was used in the time of the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. They didn't
have clocks, they didn't have watches,
right? and he said, "Nahnu ummatun
ummiyyah, la naktabu wa la nahsab." So,
when
he says about a cubit or about a lance
length above the horizon, what's meant
by that is about 10 to 15 minutes,
right? Once the sun starts rising,
once it once we see the the top of the
actual sphere of the sun, once we see
that up until
it rises a a degree clearly, distinctly
above the horizon, okay?
Which if you're in an urban environment,
if you're in a city, it's very difficult
to see that.
This is about a lance length. The
scholars, the modern scholars of fiqh
have mentioned that to be about 10 to 15
minutes.
Roughly about 10 to 15 minutes.
Okay?
Tayyib.
we are not to pray until it has risen
that high up. Also, when the sun is
at its zenith until it crosses over,
which is about about 10 minutes as well.
Likewise, when this after Asr until the
sun has set, until the disc of the sun
is completely gone, meaning until Fajr
until Maghrib is in.
These times are prohibited for optional
prayer.
Okay?
Not obligatory prayer. We get this
question very often and I can see how
someone may be confused. As a matter of
fact, I may even admit that many, many,
many years ago before I'd even began
studying, I as well was confused about
this issue. And that is that many people
will wake up
let's say they had accidentally slept
through the alarm or or whatever and
they wake up as the sun is rising.
Right? They haven't prayed Fajr.
Many people will do what?
They will wait until the sun rises above
the horizon and then pray based on the
narration that we just mentioned. And
that is incorrect application of that
narration. That narration is speaking
about optional prayers. Right? Person
prays Fajr
on time and now they just want to keep
praying and keep praying until the sun
rises. This is impermissible. And the
reason that this is impermissible, the
Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam tells
us
that this is when traditionally
many pagan cultures would pray to the
sun
when it is rising and when it is when it
is setting. Right?
When it is rising and when it is
setting. These are the times when pagan
cultures would worship their various
celestial bodies, whether that be the
sun or the moon or what have you, right?
And we notice this in the Quran, we see
that in Surat Al-An'am for instance,
Ibrahim Alaihis Salaam
Allah mentions that when he is debating
his people about the worship of the star
and then after that the moon and then
after that it's not really a star, it
was
a planet, but a celestial body
and then the moon and then the sun,
right? We see that this debate was
sparked once this thing
rose that night or that day. So, he says
right?
[Silence]
And so,
Allah mentions in Surat Al-An'am that
when the night came upon Ibrahim and he
was debating his people and
then he saw a star or a celestial body,
a planet rise and he said rhetorically,
right? He said rhetorically,
"This is my Lord." And then when it
had passed, he said, "I do not or I
do not desire as a God one who changes
and comes into existence and then
and then goes and fades into obscurity.
Likewise, when the moon
rise, when the sun rise, he said. So, we
understand from this that the pagan
cultures would often
stage their worship of the sun, of
the moon, of the stars, of the planets.
They would do this when they would rise.
When they because it to them it was a
kind of arrival. And also when it would
set, right?
And
this is why
the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
if the sun is rising, do not pray until
it is such and such above the horizon
because it rises between the two horns
of a shaitan.
And he says in another
that it sets when it sets between the
two horns of a shaitan, right? Of the
devil. And what does this mean? This
means that this is the time frame in
which the worship of these things was
most lucrative and most he was Iblis
was most able to trick humanity into
these things. So,
this is only for optional prayer. This
is not for obligatory prayer and this is
not for prayer that has a reason, a
cause,
whether that be an event
or a place
or a time.
What we mean is salawat
dhawat asbab,
meaning that
prayers that have a cause, right? They
are linked to a certain time or place or
they are linked to an event. What does
that mean?
This This prohibition also excludes
these things.
So, for example, prayer that is
connected to an event such as al-kusuf
or al-khusuf, which is the eclipse
prayer. Let's say an eclipse takes place
after Asr, an eclipse takes place after
Fajr. Does a person pray the prayer of
eclipse? Yes, this narration does not
apply to that.
Likewise,
a particular place tahiyatul
masjid. A person comes into the masjid,
right? And
you know, they are to pray before they
sit down. They are to pray before they
before they sit down. meaning that
once they come into the masjid, the
masjid is owed two raka' to
articulate that I have entered a place
of of sanctity, a place of And so,
this
this is excluded from that prohibition.
That a person So, a person who comes in
after Asr, they pray two raka', right?
Likewise,
an event. What does that mean?
Connected to an event
such as or connected to a particular
time such as
a person commonly makes two raka'
after wudu. This is known as sunnatul
wudu. The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam encouraged this.
That when a person makes wudu, that they
make two raka', right?
This does not apply to the
prohibition. Likewise,
salatul istikhara. You have to make a
decision right now, and you don't have
time to wait until after Maghrib. Can
you make salatul istikhara? Yes. Can you
make salatul tawbah? Yes. Etcetera,
etcetera, right? So, these are excluded
from this narration. This narration is
speaking only about choosing those
particular times to make additional
voluntary prayer that that in the
collective consciousness of the Muslims
will lead further down the road, perhaps
even generations away, will lead to
people becoming misguided with regards
to the purpose of that prayer. We see
this often. Right? We see that a person
will
they're they're for example, in
certain madhahib, that it is
prohibited for a person to pray
after Asr even
even
if it is tahiyatul masjid. So, what
happens?
And there are some mosques this.
You'll go inside and before Maghrib,
about 10 or 15 minutes before Maghrib,
you'll go inside, you'll see everybody
is waiting for Maghrib, but nobody is
sitting down. They're either pacing
around or standing. Everyone is
standing.
Nobody's sitting down.
Why are they standing? Because the
Prophet, sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
prohibited that a person sit down before
making tahiyatul masjid, but at the same
time he also prohibited that a person
that a person pray after Asr. So,
they're all walking around or they're
standing there waiting for Asr.
And now this leads us to a whole other
conundrum, and that is that no
narrations mention that the companions
would all be standing up in the masjid
waiting for Maghrib.
Right?
Likewise,
the idea that
you you can the idea that the narration
is that literal, meaning that do not sit
down until you pray,
even if you do not sit down until you
pray, it's not meaning that a person is
prohibited from sitting.
It means that a person is
obligated to pray.
That's the meaning of the narration.
Okay, people misconstrue this that this
narration
The prophet
Muhammad said, "If any of you comes to
the masjid, then he is not to sit until
he prays two raka. Is this narration
an obligation to pray two raka, or is it
a prohibition from sitting?"
That's the question.
Because if it is a prohibition of
sitting,
then I guess, yeah.
But that's not what is intended by the
narration. How do we know this? Well,
the
the story behind this narration is a man
came into the masjid as Jabir narrates,
while the prophet
Muhammad was giving khutbah.
And he sat down
during the khutbah. The prophet Muhammad
stopped his
train of thought that he was speaking
about, and he asked the companion,
[Silence]
He said,
He saw the man sat down. He directed his
attention to the man, paused his
narrative in the khutbah, and he said,
"Did you pray two raka?" The man said,
"No." He said,
"Pray two raka. Stand back up and pray
two raka." The man had already sat.
And then he said to the companions,
"If any of you comes to the masjid while
the khatib, the Imam on Jumu', is
giving khutbah,
then you are to not sit until you pray
two raka', and you are to make those
two raka' brief." Now,
the point here is that the man had
already sat down,
right?
But he commanded him to stand up
and pray those two raka'. So, we
understand that the issue is not a
prohibition of sitting as much as it is
an obligation to pray those two raka'.
So, if I come to the masjid and I say,
"Well, I can hang out in the masjid as
long as I but I just cannot sit
down." This is
in a way a misunderstanding of the
spirit of the narration.
So, these are a few things that we
wanted to mention.
these are things that many people
Many people are unclear about with
regards to some of these narrations. And
as we always say,
and I will repeat it all of the time
because I really hope that even if just
one person listens to this every week
and learns, if you can learn
anything, that I hope that this is one
of the things that you will learn. And
that is
a little bit of knowledge
or incomplete knowledge is more
dangerous than ignorance.
Right?
We say this all the time.
And that is the true enemy of knowledge
is not ignorance. The true enemy of
knowledge is the illusion of knowledge,
thinking that you know something.
And you know,
if we look at the world around us,
misinformation is everywhere, okay? And
the truth is very, very hard to find and
it is very precious.
Very difficult to find.
During this time because there's spent
so much data or so much nonsense poured
into the consciousness of humanity now
that we we can't even we're exhausted.
But the point is is that
one of the issues and this could be
positive, it could be negative.
I view it personally as being more
negative.
and that is the
the printing press
that is new to the Muslim ummah
with regards to religious works, okay?
Religious works.
And that is that about 150 years ago or
so when the printing press first became
mainstream in Muslim countries
the scholars of Islam and this is an
official fatwa of Azhar at the time
prohibited
that any books be printed
except for
some books on history and some books on
grammar. That was it.
They prohibited emphatically
the printing of the Quran
the printing of the narrations, the
sunan of the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam and the printing of other books
such as books of fiqh and books of law
etc.
Now a person might look at that and say,
"Why? Why are you preventing knowledge?"
We say, "No."
The reason for that was twofold. Number
one
they feared
that this knowledge would be unleashed
amongst the population
people would be literate in the sense
that they can read
but illiterate with regards to Islamic
sciences. You see, if you want to learn
these things before, you have to go
through a process of scholarship and
apprenticeship to learn properly from
the proper sources.
Right? And so, what ends up happening is
people read and they're not qualified to
read these things and they read things
that they're not ready for and things
that they haven't understood properly
and they apply their own
ideas to it or their own circumstances
to it. And this is where mistakes come
from. And this is the root of true
ignorance.
Okay? Because now
instead of having people who say, "Well,
we're not scholars. We don't know. Teach
us." Now, we have a people saying,
"We're scholars. You guys are not. We
know what we're talking about. You do
not." And then suspicion and all this
other thing comes into play.
There is a narration. It's been graded
authentic by some scholars of Islam on
the authority of Omar ibn al-Khattab.
And it could just be the words of Omar.
Either way, it's meaning is correct.
He said, "Sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
aqwa fuma aqwa ala ummati
munafiq alim al-lisan."
He said, "The thing I fear most
over my ummah,
for my people, my followers, my nation,
is a hypocrite who has a knowledgeable
tongue, knowledgeable vocabulary." This
is the most dangerous thing.
And what does this mean? This means that
a person is teaching the Quran and
Sunnah and they do not believe it. They
do not follow it. They do not adhere to
it. And that has many levels.
But, it is very dangerous for a person
to have lots of
quirky ideas from all over the place and
then just put it into play. This has
never been the way that serious
disciplines were practiced. A person
cannot just pick up a bunch of random
books and start reading and become a
doctor. That's not how that works. We as
a society agree that this person is not
a doctor, not until they learn from
other doctors, right? And it is no
difference with regards to Islamic
scholarship. As a matter of fact, it is
more strict. And so
the first reason why the scholars
initially prohibited the printing press
is number one that people would be
saturated with information and
misunderstand it, and that has clearly
happened, right? And that has led to the
downfall
of
many of the Muslims and Muslim
nations have collapsed simply because of
this reason.
The second reason though is that it
would be
easy
or easier for people to manipulate
the books that they are printing. And
this did happen, and it even happened
a few instances with the Quran.
And this is actually
one of the reasons that
Al-Hussary, rahimahullah, in Egypt, he
is the person to first record the entire
mushaf recited
on audio. He's the first person to do
that. Why did he do that? it's
mentioned that he had come to America,
and he was in a masjid in America, one
of the American cities back when they
had many scholars that would pass
through America and and come and visit
with with the Muslim communities, and he
had found a collection of masahif that
had mistakes in them.
And he had actually, well, the rumor
has it is that these were printed by
a particular country. The point The
point is is that these were
These were misprints inside in the
Quran.
And so al-Husari decided to go back and
to completely record
the recitation of the Quran from its
beginning to end
as a way of preserving it. And
alhamdulillah, since the printing press
has become so widespread,
it has been perfected with regards to
the Quran.
And
each mushaf is vetted very well.
However,
this is not the case with regards to
other books. Other books have been
changed. They have been altered. They
have been manipulated. Parts have been
removed from these books
because when the printing press was
first utilized, it was overseen by
scholars who would No book would be
taken from handwriting into the printing
press unless a scholar himself is the
one who did that process, which is
called a tahqiq, right?
But now,
there are numerous companies and they're
just printing stuff.
Stuff that should never be printed.
Stuff that people have no business
reading. And
then we had the translation era, where
this big campaign
to translate everything, right? And
there's a lot of money in this. And so,
a lot of books were translated.
And
these books are not books that every
Tom, Dick, and Harry should be
reading, as the saying goes.
This is books that can be easily
misunderstood, especially when taken
into another language. Languages are not
just a different way of saying the same
thing. Languages are a representation of
an entire culture, an entire thought,
right?
And so, linguists understand that each
language
has in it different connotations, even
the sounds that that language makes. And
so, what happens is when we take a book
Sunan Abi Dawud
or we take a book Sahih al-Bukhari,
these are very complex books. They're
not easy to read. And this is why
scholars historically throughout the
throughout the
centuries
have condensed these books, summarized
these books, abridged these books for
the common folk to read,
right? Sahih al-Bukhari has many
summaries. Sahih Muslim, Sunan Abi
Dawud, Ibn al-Qayyim is one of them who
actually summarized Sunan Abi Dawud,
right? Riyadh as-Salihin is a result
of that, the 40 narrations, and and many
other books, okay? This effort is
because scholars understand how these
books can be so easily misunderstood,
misinterpreted. And we have that now,
right? So, we have Sahih al-Bukhari
translated verbatim,
okay?
We're not given any introduction into
how to understand Sahih al-Bukhari, the
time, the place, the era, how he
constructed his book. It took him 17
years to write his book, Sahih
al-Bukhari,
right? He did it extremely meticulously.
That is his life's work. And so, now we
have it in in a language, it's been
translated, which is a problem because
now
it we have more than one person involved
in the process of conveying these ideas.
We have narrations which al-Bukhari
very, very specifically
chose and summarized and length and it's
a it's an extremely complicated book,
Sahih al-Bukhari.
And this is why it took so many years
for Sahih al-Bukhari to be properly
explained in its entirety. Right?
in in the way that it is today with with
books Fath al-Bari. And so
Sahih al-Bukhari is one of those books
that scholars have dedicated their lives
to.
Right? Such as al-Yunini. He He
dedicated his life's work to Sahih
al-Bukhari.
That's all That is the main thing he is
known for.
Right? And he spent all of his time on
Sahih al-Bukhari all of his life
collecting its different copies and
comparing and contrasting and getting
different Right? And so then we
translate it. We're not sure of the
qualifications of the translator.
And we're not saying that the translator
is not
a person who is fluent in Arabic and
English. That's only part of it.
also the translator has to know what
the author intended when he translates.
Right?
Have to know the context. Why the author
did this. What They have to be able to
see all of those you know nuances.
They translate it and then it gets
shipped across the world to a place like
America or elsewhere where we have
We could not be more radically different
than the than
al-Imam al-Bukhari in our culture in our
ways. Right? Or than the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. And there
are narrations that everybody
understands in Sahih al-Bukhari.
But then there are other things that are
confusing.
And then we have people who are
under-qualified who have not or people
that have
tell you the truth they just they
have ulterior motives. Right?
And they start to pick things out. What
is this? What is that? What does this
mean? What does that mean? Maybe a woman
can marry more than one husband. See,
here's in Sahih al-Bukhari. Maybe
homosexuality is okay. Here's in Sahih
al-Bukhari. All of them everybody uses
Sahih al-Bukhari.
Right? Everybody uses the Quran
to articulate their argument. Anybody
can understand the Quran. Anybody can
understand the Sunnah. It's the The
point isn't understanding it. The point
is understanding the Quran and Sunnah in
the way that Allah and His Messenger
intended. That's That's only a group of
people understand it that way.
Right?
But unfortunately, a lot of this has to
do with political things as well
throughout the centuries and knowledge
is power.
And so unfortunately, what has happened
is we have
regressed. We have We have more
information, but we haven't digested it.
So, we don't have any knowledge. We have
a bunch of information, no knowledge.
And everybody
is got this idea, you know, from I don't
know, watching Disney or or watching
movies or something that I'm the hero of
the movie here and I'm going to I'm
going to I'm going to bring Sahih
al-Bukhari to America or to the to the
Muslims. Everybody was doing it wrong
before me. I'm going to bring it
correctly. And that's
the first mistake. Scholarship in Islam,
leadership in Islam has nothing to do
with
being the chosen one, being the one who
does it different or does it right after
everybody has done it wrong. No.
It's exactly the opposite.
Scholarship in Islam is
I am going to try my best to make my
brick
and lay it into the temple of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala or the the the
structure of of Islam. That's that's my
mission as a scholar. It's not to be
different or to be famous or to be the
one. It's it's just for me to carry on
the legacy
and to leave it as I was given it.
That's it. That's my only job.
Right? To explain it as it was explained
to me.
and so
we have people saying all kinds of crazy
things now and they're using Sahih
al-Bukhari to do it. They're using Sahih
Muslim to do it. They're using the Quran
to do it.
Bringing into put bringing into question
things that are
that are not open to debate and they
have never been open to debate in the
history of Islam.
things that
malum min al-din bi al-darura. These are
issues that
are are are self-evident as it were,
right?
Yet we're trying to reinvent the wheel
now and anytime a people
try to start at zero and go up and
dismiss everything that has come before
them and dismiss their
forefathers in this way
as Shaykh al-Islam Rahimahullah says,
they will always they will always they
will never
proceed. They will never excel. They
go forward because every generation's
always setting it back to zero.
So
next week inshallah Ta'ala, we will
discuss the way that the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam made Qiyam
al-Layl. thank you for joining us
[Arabic recitation]